dr. Anthony foul she testifies it before
the Senate and controversial fashion
president Trump comes under fire for
telling a reporter tasks China about
coronavirus damage and the left's
transformative vision of America begins
to bear fruit I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by Express at VPN
stop putting your online data at risk
stop that get protected it expressive
VPN calm /ban want to start before I
really begin the show want to just give
a shout out to our advertising partners
who make this show possible obviously
during down economic times we understand
that people are really sort of making
sure that their bank accounts are secure
making sure they are not spending money
where it is needless to do so the
reality is that our advertisers do rely
on your business to keep in business and
we rely on our advertisers to keep in
business so we really appreciate that
you continue to do business with them
there are great folks and they make sure
that you get the products that you need
when you need them
so please continue to patronize our
advertisers we appreciate it they
appreciate it and we're all working
together to ensure that we can move
forward as this horrible situation
continue speaking of this horrible
situation obviously the economic fallout
from coronavirus continues to be
absolutely astonishingly bad over 30
million people have now lost their jobs
are talking about a ten year recovery
now might be a good time to think about
diversifying into precious metals like
maybe you should have done that before
when I told you to do so like a year ago
maybe it would've been a good idea to do
this before the stock market lost 1/3 of
its value and we don't know where the
stock market is going right now frankly
it seems to a lot of people like the
stock market is sort of disconnected
from underlying market fundamentals
given the fact that it's actually bumped
in the last month despite the fact that
there's not really a lot of good news on
the horizon well right now it might be a
pretty good time to think about
diversify at least a little bit into
precious metals and you know what I'm
gonna say talk to my friends over at
Birch gold to do so Colbert's gold right
now and you could convert your
traditional IRA or 401k into a precious
metals IRA again is just good sense that
I versified you diversify even your
stock holdings you should diversify
between the resources that you do hold
before May 31st with a qualifying
purchase Birch gold will give you a free
emergency kit it's a backpack loaded
with stuff you cannot buy right now so
safeguard your savings with Birch gold
and they will help safeguard your family
like that in mind there's no obligation
you have nothing to lose to take that
first step
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau don't wait until the
market drops more to protect your
hard-earned savings get your free
emergency kept by texting Ben - 47 47 47
and diversified today again text Ben -
47 47 47 text my name Ben - 47 47 47
okay so the controversy
the morning is that dr. Anthony fat she
testified before the Senate where he
explained that if people do not pay
attention to the federal guidelines
maybe they will be reopening too soon
and then there will be consequences to
reopening soon there were several health
experts testifying before the Senate
Health Committee on Tuesday morning
pretty much everybody was was doing this
via internet dr. Robert Redfield the
director of the CDC warned the Senate
Health Committee on Tuesday morning were
not out of the woods yet that was the
day after President Trump declared we've
met the moment and we have prevailed dr.
Redfield is one of four top health
officials testifying remotely by video
three of whom in some form of
self-isolation
after exposure to a White House official
that includes dr. Anthony Fauci and
Stephen Hahn the FDA Commissioner and
doctor Falchi had submitted his
testimony beforehand he was expected to
tell the panel there could be needless
suffering and death if the country opens
prematurely as opposed to what needful
suffering and death me nobody is
interested in killing people the
question is when is it appropriate to
reopen what are the costs and effects
what are exactly the risks he did say in
his opening statement that the idea of
having a treatment or vaccine available
to facilitate the reentry of college
students into the fall term would be a
bit of a bridge too far well one of the
big problems here is that nobody is
posing any alternative to reopening and
cautious and calculated fashion there
just seems to be this idea out there
that if you just keep saying that we
need to be locked down and this amounts
to some sort of strategy and that
obviously is not the case Factory said
the consequences could be really serious
if states skip federal guidelines in
order to reopen he said it's not just
about reopening at the right time but
having the capability to respond when
some infections return but that is a
situation you would imagine that the
governor's are going to be best
qualified to answer right a that that
would be the real question is is if you
are a governor of a state and you know
what exactly your state's medical
capacity is aren't you better qualified
to say what your state's medical
capacity is than the federal government
in fact isn't the federal government
getting its information on what you need
from you know andrew Cuomo is dictating
to the federal government what kind of
resources he needed the federal
government was listening Andrew Cuomo
was wrong and he was saying they needed
40,000 ventilators they didn't need half
of that apparently hey but what we are
seeing in in sort of the the federal
oversight is let let's put it this way I
think the doctor foul she knows more
than I do about this stuff for sure I
think that he is an expert on
epidemiology for sure I also do not
think that
he is the sole repository of all risk
assessment when it comes to the best
public policy and I also think that dr.
Fowler gets blamed if there is an
inordinate number of deaths he does not
get blamed if the economy is locked down
in other words it is normal human it is
just the normal human tendency to stick
within your area of expertise in the
area of epidemiology it is true that if
you want to prevent more deaths than
what you're going to do is you're going
to call for extended lockdown from long
periods of time until it is
quote-unquote safer to go outside until
some sort of therapeutic or vaccine has
been found realistically speaking that
is not a balancing of interest that is
just you being an expert in your field
if you ask an economist what is the best
for the economy the economists would
probably say best for the economy just
take the hit and go on right and that
would be a bad answer - in other words
it is the job of policymakers to balance
all these competing interests dr. Falchi
isn't the only voice in the room the
media are treating him that way because
he is saying the sort of stuff that they
would like to hear in other words let's
lock down for a very very long period of
time so dr. foutch you for example
suggested that it might be too much to
reopen campuses in September well that
is a risk reward calculation because
again these are a bunch of 20 year olds
20 year olds are not really at risk from
Kovac 19 the the level of risks to 20
year olds is extraordinarily minimal and
it may actually be better for the better
for the general health for a bunch of 20
year olds to be on campus than at home
hanging out with their six-year-old
parents doctor fat shouldn't really
explain why you know people should not
go back to campus well doctor factory
did talk a little bit about vaccinations
here's what dr. fat she had to say
moving on to vaccines there are at least
eight candidate coping 19 vaccines in
clinical development the NIH has been
collaborating with a number of
pharmaceutical companies at various
stages of development I will describe
one very briefly which is not the only
one the one that we have been involved
in heavily developing with Moore Danner
it's a messenger RNA platform okay well
obviously that would be a good thing the
federal government is talking about 40
to 50 million coronavirus s a month by
September okay so forget about the 50
million a day that people are talking
about yeah that then in happening or
even 3 million a day that ain't
happening that'd be 90 million a month
here's Anthony Fauci talking about
warning against reopening and again
nobody wants to reopen an uncalibrated
fashion I'm
just bewildered by the media's coverage
that Brian Kemp is doing is doing
something deeply wrong by reopening in
somewhat calibrated fashion and Rhonda
stances doing something totally wrong
but you're a palace in Colorado isn't
doing anything wrong in Tim Walz in
Minnesota isn't doing anything wrong and
and Steve Bullock in Montana isn't doing
anything wrong but why is it that when
it comes to democratic states they can
do no wrong but when it comes to
Republican states doing exactly the same
thing then all they do is run anyway
here's dr. fat you talking about
reopening what I've expressed then and
again is my concern that if some areas
city states or what-have-you
jump over those various checkpoints and
prematurely open up without having the
capability of being able to respond
effectively and efficiently my concern
is that we will start to see little
spikes that might turn into outbreaks
okay so that okay notice what he says
there because had very important what he
says is he is afraid of overall in the
health care system that's really what
he's saying no but he's afraid of is
that there will be a big spike and you
don't have the capacity to at least test
the spikes and you don't have the
capacity to handle the spikes over the
healthcare system he is not saying that
we have to remain locked down until this
thing is dead and this is a major
distinction because the media are
reading this is pouchy saying that we
have to lock this thing down until
basically the end of time until the
vaccine is developed and it seems like
the American people are taking it that
way
I mean if you read the media coverage of
this it's really intensely bad really
really bad media coverage I've been I've
been honing in on this for a while
because the fact is that the media the
the so-called experts in our media are
not actually properly quoting even the
experts in the health field so you get
pieces like this from the New York Times
as states rushed to reopen scientists
fear a coronavirus comeback
officials are under pressure to restart
the economy but many states are moving
too quickly researchers say the cost may
be measured in lost lives in other words
people are rushing and now they're
killing people you're killing grandma
according to the New York Times millions
of working people in small business
owners who cannot earn money while
sheltering at home are facing economic
ruin so dozens of states seeking to ease
the pain are coming out of lockdown most
of not met even minimal criteria for
doing so safely and some are reopening
even as coronavirus cases rise inviting
disaster the much-feared second wave of
infection may not wait until fall many
scientists say and instead may become a
storm of wavelets breaking unpredict
across the country the reopening will
proceed nonetheless the question now
scientists say is whether the nation can
minimize the damage the damage by
intelligently adopting new tactics
evidence is mounting the masks are far
more effective at stopping transmission
than previously realized and remember
these same experts two months ago were
telling us don't wear a mask it's a
complete waste of time across the nation
testing remains wholly inadequate but
home use nasal swabs and saliva tests
are on the way that may provide a
clearer picture of where the virus is
Americans are lining up for antibody
tests that may reveal who has some
immunity early survey suggests more
Americans may carry antibodies than
initially thought employers are moving
to design safer workplaces but well it
may still be possible to blunt the
impacts of reopening the nation is
finding even this goal difficult and
then they talk about how people are not
staying six feet apart and there may be
silent carriers of the virus and they
talked about how some epidemiological
models are worrying about the
possibility of an outbreak but again the
point here is not the number of cases
gonna go up everybody knows the number
of cases gonna go up the question is
whether it overwhelms the healthcare
system and I feel like I'm repeating
myself here but that's because the media
refused to get the message and so you
end up with people like Chris Cuomo
saying idiotic things on on national TV
like nearly every night Chris Cuomo gets
out there and he says we don't have the
testing and tracing in place in order to
stop the virus it doesn't stop the virus
Chris Cuomo said none of the states that
have reopened none has the capacity to
test and trace the way they need to okay
first of all I think that the guy who
like violated his own quarantine rules
that he could go visit his second house
that that guy probably is not your best
source on this the guy who gives stop
interviews to his brother who was
involved in some of the worst policy
planning for the corona virus into
anybody in America probably he's not a
great source but beyond that beyond the
fact that Chris Cuomo is into a great
source what does it mean has the
capacity to test and trace the way they
need to what I would love to hear him
describe exactly what a test and trace
regimen looks like that is sufficient
for reopening and the answer is that
nobody is providing any of that instead
there's always safety to be found and
saying we're not ready yet saying we're
not ready yet it's but there are
inherent risks in opening up we all
understand this but the question is when
are those risks well calibrated and when
are you willing to take the risks
because it turns out that there are
risks to inaction as well so take a war
analogy which apparently people like
doing these days trying to compare the
virus to a war back during the Civil War
President Lincoln had a general named
George McClellan George McClellan was he
like to style himself as little Napoleon
and the he was this this kind of short
dude who was very very good at providing
military training to his troops but
extraordinarily extraordinarily reticent
in using his troops to break the back of
the Confederacy and President Lincoln
became increasingly agitated with
McClellan and eventually he ended up
firing McClellan this actually caused
enough of a controversy in 1864 George
McClellan actually ran against Abraham
Lincoln for the presidency but George
McClellan who was again this supposed
great warrior was really really reticent
to use his army and so eventually
Lincoln fired him and he put in place
generals who were willing to use the
army people like grant and people like
Sherman that came with additional risks
to the troops no question but also it
turns out that is kind of important when
the Civil War now again this isn't a war
and we're trying to preserve as many
lives as humanly possible but it is also
true that if we all cower behind the the
lockdown mentality without doing the
capable calculation of risks the safest
thing to do is never to fight a battle
safest thing to do is never to come out
of lockdown presumably but it is not the
safest thing in terms of having a
functioning economy and having a free
America and having a functioning and
prosperous nation and and by the way in
terms of saving lives on the other end
from suicide and drug overdose and from
deaths of despair and from the the
complete collapse of the American Way of
life
so unless somebody's providing like an
absolute metric and an explanation for
those metrics I don't want to hear vague
terms like the testing and tracing are
simply not up to snuff from from Chris
Cuomo he doesn't know anything about
this he doesn't know more than I do
about this and if I'm gonna hear from an
expert I want to hear why the testing
and tracing needs to be at a certain
stage and what exactly those stages look
like because if you listen to Mike
DeWine he's reopening before they have
hit the fourteen-day consistent downturn
in diagnosed cases in Ohio but he says
our testing and tracing has now been
ramped up so that we're okay and our
resources are okay I trust Mike DeWine
on that more than a truss course Cuomo
and frankly more than I trust Anthony
pouchy because guess who's gonna bear
the brunt of the fallout if that thing
goes wrong it's gonna be Mike DeWine not
Anthony foutch a man in a second we're
gonna get to some theories of reopening
and what that would look like and I also
want to talk about the the effect of bad
media coverage because there's a poll
number today that just demonstrates the
wild disconnect that has been Creed
in the American mind between what is
rational to expect and what is
irrational to expect at this point well
get to that in just a moment first let's
talk about the fact when you're at work
you really probably don't think all that
much about the fact that your IT
department is protecting your online
activity but here's the reality in the
time since I started using expressvpn
hacking methods have grown evermore
sophisticated and you are working from
home right now which means your IT
department is not protecting you I've
been talking about expressvpn on the
show for so long you already understand
why encrypting your network data is
important
you might be thinking security threats
don't affect you personally but not
using Express VPN is like leaving your
front door all mocked every time you go
out sure nothing might happen for years
when a break-in does happen it's gonna
be devastating one of the easiest ways
to secure your internet data is with
Express at VPN you click one button on
your computer or smartphone and you are
now protected so here's the only
question why haven't you gone out and
gotten expressive VPN yet I've been
using it for years it's super easy to
use you install it on your computer one
click you are now protected it does not
slow down your internet which makes a
huge difference to me since I run an
internet company is it my special link
right now an expressvpn com /ban get an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free protect your internet today with
the VPN I trust to keep my data safe
that's expressive VPN calm slash pen
once more expressvpn calm slash pen expr
ESS VPN calm slash man for more
information ok so when I say the media
coverage leads to some pretty egregious
public relations results and
expectations that simply do not meet
with reality here's an example there's a
Gallup poll out it shows that 68% of
Americans say a vaccine is needed before
returning to normal life now I don't
know what they qualify as normal life
just normal life mean before you go to a
ballgame
okay maybe but if what you mean by
normal life is like going back to work
and you're waiting for a vaccine there
is the significant possibility that a
vaccine will appear never that there
will not be a successful vaccine for
this thing in fact there are new reports
out today the NIH is suggesting it might
need more than one round of vaccine
there might need multiple vaccines and
now Americans are also fibbing about
that so 68% of Americans are saying they
need a vaccine before they return to
normal life but Gallup is finding that
more people now say they're going to
visit others in their homes 16% of
Americans reported they visited somebody
else's home or apartment in the last 24
hours alone which is an uptick since
March the avoidance of small gatherings
has decreased mostly among independents
Republicans it's down 10 percentage
points among independents and down seven
percentage points among Republicans
which by the way I mean that's a bigger
change among independents than among
Republicans so for all the talk about
partisanship the reality is that most
Americans are just not willing to
continue to avoid other human beings
because this is not natural to human
beings normally I've talked about this
before but normally in times of crisis
you go and you seek out other human
beings for commonality you go to church
right you find other people you can find
solidarity and during 9/11 people sought
out crowds to be in because not only
does there feel like inherent safety in
numbers also we were all grieving
together and mourning together this is
really really difficult because you're
being told that the only way to prevent
further tragedy is basically to stay
away from other human beings as far as
possible
which is really deeply unnatural but
here's the problem if 68 percent of
Americans are saying that they do not
feel like returning to normal life until
there's a vaccine we're never returning
to normal life gang I mean it could be
12 to 18 months at the at the inside
right not at the outside at the inside
and let's be real about this blue states
are reopening too so while the media is
trying to divide this into blue states
versus red state LA is set to reopen in
speeches on Wednesday according to a
tweet from the county new rules will be
in place physical activities like
running swimming and surfing will be
allowed sedentary activity like
sunbathing and picnic and will be
prohibited I don't even know if the hell
that means
like how seriously I don't know what
that means have these people ever been
to a beach what do they think people do
on a beach like if my kids go into the
water and then they get out of the water
do they think that my kids are gonna run
straight from the car into the water and
then straight back into my car that's
not how any of this works how about this
how about you enforce rules that make
sense like social distancing rules like
you guys are too close together move
five feet apart it's a big beach how
about that masks or face coverings must
be worn unless you're in the water which
makes perfectly zero sense when you are
more than six feet away from people
again the media are so irresponsible
about this stuff so they're making a big
deal yesterday in the media about the
fact that over at the White House people
were supposed to be wearing masks and so
the members of the media we're all
wearing masks but they were also
socially distancing which again this is
like wearing a mask in your own car when
you're by yourself you don't have to do
that guys if you are ten feet away from
another person you don't have to wear a
mask if you're outdoors this is
ridiculous but there's so much bad
information and misinterpretation of
information it's really rather wild
it's really quite insane and the
American people are taking in the bad
and
formation and they are also miss
evaluating their own risk because of
this and miss evaluating the likelihood
of a vaccine arriving any time in the
near future
according to Bloomberg several vaccines
will likely be needed to combat the
corona virus and immunize groups of
people in America and abroad according
to the US National Institute of Health
Director Francis Collins Collins's
physician and geneticist who leads the
agency overseeing the u.s. research
response to the pandemic he said my
expectation is and I'm a bit of an
optimist we don't find out there's only
one of these vaccines that work but
rather two or three of them come through
the trials looking as though they're
safe and effective
they'll have somewhat different
characteristics of where they work best
so you might need to do some matching
then of which vaccine goes to which
particular population so according to
Collins the plan which is a very
optimistic one is to begin to have doses
this fall
first with ten million then maybe a
hundred million by late fall maybe 300
million by January but is that a
realistic assessment of the situation
who the hell knows and also are we all
going to stay locked in our houses until
January is that the actual plan here and
if it is then you better give me a damn
guarantee that there's gonna be a
vaccine by January you're talking about
destroying the entire world economy like
literally the entire world economy not
existing by January every small business
in America is already going under they
in fact people are getting so desperate
for speeding up a vaccine that
scientists are debating whether to try a
so-called human challenge trial normally
you give somebody a vaccine and you wait
for somebody to sort of naturally
acquire the disease to see if the
vaccine worked now what they're talking
about is we give you the vaccine and
then we deliberately infect you with
coronavirus to see if the vaccine works
and there are some scientists who are
suggesting that maybe we need to do this
in order to speed everything up they may
very well be right okay there's another
possibility here and that possibility is
then we need to transpile a shindig and
the fact that we were treating all
populations as equally susceptible to
death that we are treating all
having severe health problems from komen
19 is just foolishness now again there
will be some people who are young who
get very sick from this statistical
probability does not mean that people
who are on the wrong side of the
statistical probability aren't affected
they are if two and one if two and
10,000 people die from kovat 19 that
means that 9,998 people don't die from
Kovach 19 but it means that two people
do right so I mean if somebody you'll
hear anecdotal evidence and this is one
of the again my bugaboos in the media
they will say things like it's true that
people above the age of 80
on mass from this thing and it's really
dangerous for those above 80 but people
who are 30 are dying - that doesn't help
me in any way make a statistical
calculation it doesn't help me calculate
risks at all Andrew Oswald has a very
good piece over in the the Irish time -
Andrew Oswald is a professor of
economics and behavioral science at
University of Warwick and he says that
his strategy would be allow the young
people to restart their lives and the
economy he says the own are far far
safer than older people this is because
for biological reasons young humans have
a much stronger immune response to
almost all viral attacks on the body
including to a Koba 19 attacked and we
forced our youth inside as though they
were at serious risk like the old when
they're not in the UK the fatality rate
among those in their early 20s for
example is 2 in 10,000 among those aged
in their 60s it's 80 times that so you
know this would be a useful stat or if
you told young people okay here's video
older people are highly likely to be
damaged by this as in like 160 out of
every 10,000 people who are above the
age of 60 are going to die of this but
you it's 2 in 10,000 let's put it this
way if somebody said to you here here's
here's your choice today your choice is
I'm going to give you a giant giant vat
of marbles it is 10,000 marbles 2 of
those marbles are gonna be black 9,998
of those marbles were going to be white
here is your choice you can either put
your hand into that vat and pick a
marble or you can lose your entire
income not just this year but you can do
it for like a couple of years minimum
right you can watch our entire way of
life disintegrates or you can pick a
marble how many people would actually
pick the marble the vast majority of
young people would pick the marble if
you're older you probably would not pick
the marble because again the odds are
better that you're gonna pick the wrong
marble and if it's black marble then you
die right that that is the actual
statistical calculation it is an amazing
thing that so many members of the media
are unwilling to give people the tranche
to information on health risks here and
I just don't understand why why when
Anthony found she testifies when dr.
Burks testifies when they do this sort
of stuff
the first thing they don't say is let me
explain the risk factors for each
particular population why is that not
like the first thing that we talk about
and the answer is because in some ways
the vagueness
he sent the miasmatic sense that we are
all equally at risk that is the largest
factor stumping for the
lockdowns the largest factors something
from lockdowns is this belief that you
or your friends are equally likely
likely to die as an eight-year-old or if
you're less likely to die it something
marginally so not it's exponentially so
not hugely so according to this piece in
the the Irish times the key advantages
of a rolling age release strategy which
would begin with youngest adult age
groups and then we're gradually up the
age range our it recognizes we cannot
wait indefinitely to reopen the economy
it's fair because it targets and helps
the group currently hit hardest hit
hardest and financially because we'll
actually pay people to stay home if
you're older it is the safest way to
have an exit strategy until the vaccine
is available by the way it is also true
that the jobs most likely to require you
to be there are probably the jobs that
are most likely to need young bodies in
other words if you are sixty and you are
working there's a good chance that
you're working on your computer and they
are not in manual labor cuz you're sixty
rather the reality is that if you are in
a physical labor intensive industry it
is highly likely that you are
disproportionately young because younger
people are capable of lifting heavier
objects they're capable of driving
longer hours they're capable of driving
trucks for a longer write this this
columnist suggests the young are gonna
be the most troublesome in the most huh
and the hardest keep inside anyway like
this policy is geared towards something
that looks like reality you know what
isn't these interminable statements that
we're just gonna remain in lockdown
indefinitely that's not going to work as
I've said before vagary is the enemy of
obedience if you are vague about your
rules people are not going to obey them
if you are pretty specific about your
rules and what you expect people to do
people at least know what to expect and
if they know what to expect then they
can obey the rules but this idea that
we're just going to hold out
indefinitely and we'll kind of let you
know when it's kind of safe but then
we'll rip you if it's not signaling none
of that is effective it's not effective
policymaking and just a second we'll get
to what would be effective policymaking
beyond simply trenching out young
populations namely protecting the
nursing homes as I've been talking about
first let's talk about the fact that if
you are a a male there's a good shot
that you will start losing your hair by
the time you are thirty-five years old
male pattern baldness does run in my
family it's one of the reasons that I
have been using keeps two out of three
dudes are going to experience some form
of male pattern baldness by the time
they are 35 the best way to prevent hair
loss is to do something about it while
you still have hair on your head you
just have to go to a doctor's office for
your hair loss prescription now thanks
to keeps you can visit a doctor online
and get hair loss medication delivered
directly to your home they make it easy
the delivery
medication every three months she can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
in awkward doctor visits of the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there they have access you may have
tried them before probably never afford
this price prevention is key once you
start losing your hair it probably ain't
coming back you need to make sure that
you are getting what you need in order
to maintain the hair again the reason
that I've been taking it male pattern
baldness runs in my family thank God for
the yarmulke and this is the reason why
you need keeps ke PS calm /ban to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that is ke e PS calm / ben if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss keeps calm / Ben and you'll
receive your first month of treatment
for free plus you're gonna save a lot of
money as opposed to just going and
picking up some sort of prescription
it's it is a great great service check
the amount keeps calm so I've been save
your hair now cuz you ain't gonna be
able to say that later him mean well as
I say one of the keys to actually
crafting an effective policy here would
be protecting the nursing homes which is
of course exactly what so many failed to
do right and the fact is that if you
look at the population in nursing homes
you could peek by Chris Pope at City
Journal org looking at the effect of
nursing homes
it basically says in 2016 nursing homes
house 1.3 million Americans 39 percent
aged 85 or over 800,000 more lived in
his sister living facilities over two
million Americans living in nursing
homes or assisted living as of 2016
nursing residents are extremely
vulnerable to coronavirus due to
multiple comorbidities 72% have
hypertension 38% heart disease
32% diabetes even under normal
circumstances this population faces
disproportionately high mortality risks
in 2016 nursing home residents made up
0.4% of the US population they accounted
for 19 percent of deaths right now that
wouldn't beat Kovan that's just like
death death comes for older people who
have comorbidities in reality of life
but the revolver ability of nursing home
residents is simply not due to
demographics of age and illness nursing
homes have long been particularly
susceptible to infectious disease in
2016 forty five percent of nursing homes
had infection control deficiencies as
many as three hundred and eighty
thousand people die every year of
infections in long-term care facilities
so what should be priority number one
cleaning out the nursing homes ensuring
the nursing home staff has tested right
these would be all the things that we
actually need to do you do that and you
can start talking about reopening and
again the fact that this is turned into
a partisan issue is truly astonishing
because Europe is
moving toward reopening a Europe doesn't
have American partisan politics to blame
Italy is moving toward reopening Germany
is moving toward reopening the
Netherlands is moving toward like every
Britain is moving toward reopening in
very very significant fashion is that
because of Trump is that because of the
evil Republicans by the way you know who
else is talking about reopening
Democrats Connecticut's governor who is
a Democrat says yeah I think what's time
for us to reopen I mean most of our
deaths are happening in nursing homes
and let's protect the nursing homes and
let's move toward reopening is this
because the evil Connecticut governor is
an evil evil Republican or do we just
ignore him in our coronavirus critical
coverage because he is not a Republican
I am confident we've doubled the amount
of testing in the last week we're gonna
double it again in the next week we're
able to go after every single first
responder everybody in our nursing homes
we're testing in the door to the
electric both factories everybody going
in and out knows that they're been
tested and safe so this is all May 20th
Missourian and run making sure we have
the protective gear in place we have the
testing in place and the track and trace
we're ready to go I think by the way you
know who else is ready to go I mean I
know hero of the Republic Andrew Cuomo
he says listen we're turning toward
reopening to one week ago he was saying
my mom's life isn't worth a single
reopening and now he's like oh yeah by
the way we're on the other side of the
mount we kind of have to reopen yeah no
bleep Sherlock so you tell me Chris
right talk to your brother is the
testing and tracing available in New
York are they ready to go in New York
you tell me or is it only that you say
that everything is insufficient when
it's a Republican opening up at state
now the decline has gotten to a point
where we are just about where we started
the journey so to turn to reopening
because we have abated the worst by what
we've done and now we can intelligently
turn towards reopening and that's May
15th that's this Friday and local
regions of all of course the state
should start to prepare for it and
people as well
okay so again amazing amazing like only
Democrats get away with this sort of
stuff Republicans do not so here is a
perfect example
so the Trump administration has been
ripped up and down the Trump
administration got people their
ventilators
the Trump administration gave governor's
what they need I will say that it is it
is a there election of political Duty
for the Trump campaign not to have cut
an ad just showing Democrats over and
over and over again saying we got what
we needed from the White House every
single major Democrat has said this the
Governor of California has said it the
governor of New York has said at the
governor of New Jersey has said it every
major governor in every blue state has
said when we asked the federal
government for something we got what we
needed how the Trump campaign has not
put out a video just demonstrating it
the gap between the media coverage and
what the governors are saying is
absolutely beyond me it's political
dereliction of duty it's unbelievable
it's just it's unthinkable that they
haven't done this yet truly but Jared
Kushner yesterday he is correct he said
if you needed events later you got one
remember when Jared Kushner was ripped
up and down for suggesting that maybe
people were exaggerating the number of
ventilators that they need remember he
suggested by the way we're a backup
system and States should actually
primarily be looking for events lighters
on their own but we're here to help and
they got ripped up and down very evil
Jared Kushner evil evil evil Jared
Kushner guess what the ventilators were
there in fact now we're talking about a
surplus in this country of tens of
thousands of ventilators because all the
media could shout about for months on
end was the need for ventilators which
by the way are about 10 percent
effective once you're in the ICU here is
Jared Kushner yesterday we all came
together we worked very closely with New
York we sent them four thousand four
hundred ventilators we've sent them
money we've sent them resources we sent
them people we sent them masks
the goal here was just to make sure that
we can get all the resources we needed
to the frontline to make sure the people
who were in danger from the virus got
what they needed and thankfully in New
York and throughout the country anyone
who needed a ventilator got a ventilator
and we've been able to bring good
results of the country okay that is
correct but the media have an agenda and
the agenda is trump is evil in Trump is
wrong so yesterday President Trump
talked about meeting the moment he said
we've met the moment we've prevailed
okay well again I would have been very
hesitant on a political level ever to
declare victory in the middle of a
pandemic right that's just not something
that you want to do and I don't think
Trump was fully doing that but that
certainly had the media covered it
because they were always going to cover
it that way but when President Trump
says that we gave people what they
needed he is right so here as president
Trump yesterday in every generation
through every challenge and hardship and
danger America's risen to the task we
have met the moment and we have
prevailed Americans do
whatever it takes to find solutions
pioneer breakthroughs and harness the
energies we need to achieve a total
victory day after day we're making
tremendous strides with the dedication
of our doctors and nurses these are
incredible people these are brave people
these are warriors he is his right about
all of that now that was covered by the
media as those who use hanging a mission
accomplished banner across the White
House he never said anything like that
as you'll see in just a second the media
do have an agenda here and their agenda
is to rip Trunk no matter what he does
no matter what he said I mean it really
is astonishing there are plenty of times
when from said stuff we're all
criticized and I'll say that was
incredibly dumb he certainly should not
have said that there are times when
he'll say something says vulgar and vile
he certainly shouldn't have said that
and today President Trump is on Twitter
and he's talking about Joe Scarborough
being a murderer or something idiotic
and ridiculous like that that was not
yesterday yesterday the media decided
for no reason at all that Trump was in
the middle of the meltdown no what's
happening is that our media are melting
down right now because they are not
giving you proper information they are
only focused solely and completely on
how can they use this as a club to beat
Trump with I mean really when I say
something can we I mean the political
media again want to make a distinction
there are people who actually report on
health policy and many of those people
are very good I will cite again the
Washington Post health care page there
their health policy 202 page it's very
good The Wall Street Journal same thing
their health reporters at various
outlets that are actually doing a good
job and then there's the political media
and the political media absolutely suck
the people who are the White House
reporters they are just garbage the
people who are on TV and all they are
interested in doing is getting their
momentary clip that moment of Fame where
they took on the president like Sam
Donaldson in the old days or Dan Rather
in the old days standing up and
lecturing Ronald Reagan no you just look
like a douche bag seriously and that's
not on the president I'll give you a
perfect example of this yesterday's
posturing nonsense get to that in just a
second first we are home more than usual
these days but it's still hard to keep a
close eye on things more deliveries can
mean more boxes left unattended and more
opportunities for packages to go missing
plus I gotta tell you living in LA
there's more and more criminality these
days my good friend Dave Rubin he had
his mailbox robbed yesterday somebody
literally just walked up to his mailbox
open up his mailbox and took his stuff
he has that on video because of ring and
now he has submitted it to the police my
friend the other day his house was
robbed his video from ring comm directly
to the
hopefully the police will do their job
and track these people down as mayor's
are releasing criminals into public
areas and not arresting them and keeping
them in jail crime rates are going up
and that means that you really need to
make sure you know what is going on
inside and outside your house this is
why you need ring ring gives you
protection at every corner video
doorbells let you answer the door and
check in on your home anytime keep an
eye on your doorstep or speak to
delivery people when you can't come to
the door without door security cameras
you can check in on every part of your
house and never miss a moment smart
lighting will brighten up the blind spot
to make sure you always come home to a
brightly lit house full home security
systems give you everything you need to
protect your family pets and property
you get a special offer on the ring
welcome kit when you go to ring calm /
pen that welcome kit includes the ring
video doorbell 3 and the chime Pro it's
all you need to start building that
custom security for your home today go
to ring calm / band that is ring calm /
bed and go check them out right now ring
calm / ben-ari in just a second we are
going to be getting to the insanity of
the media because they were claiming
yesterday they Trump melted down at a
press conference he did not the media
melts in town and they exposed
honestly they expose themselves in
tremendous ways they expose themselves
like a porn star at a Las Vegas
Convention it was amazing I'll get to
that in a second first I want to tell
you about Daily wires newest most
exclusive membership here the all-access
all-access membership it's a premium
level of membership all access members
get the benefits of our other membership
tiers including an ad-free website
experience access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library access to
the shows mail bags and the full three
hours of the men Shapiro show along with
dedicated editorials from law all access
members also get other amazing benefits
including of course the singular
irreplaceable leftist cheers tumbler
they also get to join live exclusive
online QAS Daily wires new discussion
feature available on both the website
and the daily wire app they also get to
participate in all access live our
brand-new interactive programming
featuring one of us daily wire host is
we hang out with you each night 8 p.m.
Pacific 5 p.m. 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific I did one last night if you
missed it well that's sad but I'll be
doing another one later this week Matt
Walsh will be hosting you tonight and
let me tell you there is no party like a
mount Walsh party so get excited
heading over to Daley wire.com slash
subscribe she joins daily wires
all-access Club with the new membership
or an upgrade get 10% off with coupon
code Shapiro that is daily wire.com
slash subscribe see you there you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so this is all insanity again the media
have lost their mind so here was the
moment yesterday that made all the
rounds whatever Trump meltdown was
trending on Twitter so let me show you
the so-called meltdown so president
Trump is asked a question by a CBS
reporter named YJ Jang okay and the
question is utterly stupid it's an
idiotic question
it truly idiotic question and say it's a
typical gotcha
mr. president why are you so mean bad
and ugly question right when mr.
president when did you stop beating your
wife question and this is the question
that you get when the political
reporters are in charge again I
suggested that the White House stopped
doing press conferences with President
Trump and basically entirely not because
Trump is wildly miss handling them
although sometimes he does the real
reason is because the political media
are not giving the American public the
information they needed so funny the
political media are like we shouldn't
show Trump on TV because he's giving
misinformation what about the fact that
your entire agenda is completely
directed toward the politics of the
situation and making political hey as
opposed to you know the actual question
that Americans want answered like how
safe are we gonna be what are the risk
calculations and are we going to die it
does seem like those would be more
relevant consideration so how about you
get your economic team up there and your
health team up there and you have the
economic and health teams from the
newspapers ask the questions because
these people are asking the dumbest
questions ever
I mean seriously I've interviewed a lot
of the same people who are being brought
up to these press conferences right I've
interviewed Burks I've interviewed Mike
Pence I've interviewed Scott Gottlieb
I've interviewed like a bevy of public
health experts and if you actually
really watch the interviews on the
Sunday specials or listen to them what
you'll hear is me asking extremely
specific questions about what is the
nature of the testing one of the success
rates what can we expect from them what
level of prevalence do they have to have
right like what what is the herd
immunity that we need to reach all right
these are the questions that we need to
know right what is the timeline for the
rollout of vaccines those are the
questions we need to know instead we get
this kind of posturing bull bleep from
from people who I guess can tangentially
in some way call themselves reporters
like CBS is why shushing and then
posture as a victim so here is the
exchange between Trump and why is your
checking that ledge will blow up why is
this a global competition to you if
everyday Americans are still losing
their lives and we're still seeing more
cases every day well they're losing
their lives okay before we get to
Trump's answer
that question is so bad and so
ridiculous and so stupid the reason it's
bad and stupid and ridiculous is because
Trump before this he claims that the
United States is now testing more than
any other country down a raw basis
that's true on a on a per capita basis
it's approaching the truth I think last
I checked okay now why is he comparing
how we're doing to other countries
because you guys keep saying that we're
lagging based on other countries and so
he has been responding to that but
according to why is it so her question
is why do you keep comparing us to other
countries when Americans are dying
because it's sort of relevant to
determine our success levels in testing
to compare us to other countries because
our test levels are never going to be
sufficient to meet 50 million a day so
it seems more reasonable to compare us
to how our other countries who are
successful doing is it perfectly
reasonable it's a dumbass question and a
perfectly reasonable thing for the
presidents of the United States to
compare how we're doing to other
countries is what we do every single day
is what world ah meters does what johns
hopkins does when we look at deaths per
hundred thousand that what do you think
we're doing what do you think we're
doing okay so it's an idiotic question
and here was trump's answer well they're
losing their lives everywhere in the
world and maybe that's a question you
should ask China sir why are you saying
that to me
specifically I'm telling you I'm not
saying it's specifically to anybody I'm
saying it to anybody that would ask a
nasty question please go ahead next
place but you didn't you called on me I
did and you didn't respond and now I'm
calling on sorry just a young lady in
the back please I just want to let my
colleague okay ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much appreciate it thank
you very much
okay that's not that's not a meltdown
because what happened there is that he
then called on another reporter who
raised her hand and she seated her time
back to the woman who was busy screaming
at Trump basically busy busy take by the
way taking off her mask just so she
could get on camera right that's what
she does so we hear that look at us
we're masked up just up because we're so
we are so virtuous but you know what
this is my bit my big moment on camera
I'm taking off now so you can see that
I'm Chinese and that's why you're asking
the question so you look at okay so
question did from know she was Chinese
or not right of Chinese extraction or
not she's American I assume she's of
Chinese extraction as my understanding
so if he if no one knew that she was of
Asian extraction or Chinese extraction
before she removed the mask then it's
not racist from by the way that raises
date anyway
he's been saying for months ask China
about the levels of death ask China's
about the levels of course we should ask
China about the levels of death this is
China's damned fault China is still
manipulating the wh o to keep Taiwan out
of hearings on this stuff China still
won't answer straight questions as to
how this thing escaped Wuhan they still
won't allow an investigation as to how
this thing's started Trump has been
saying talk to China for a long time so
just because this reporter happens to be
I assume of Chinese extraction I don't
even know right she makes that the issue
he doesn't but then she's like why are
you asking me that are you saying that
because I'm Chinese okay this is the
most garbage stupid form of media
naturally the entire media jump on this
oh brian Stelter just journalism up the
wazoo right media watchdog brian Stelter
he says this is racist here is brian
Stelter really roll in that are in a
racist i think what we saw in that
exchange of Weiser jiang is something
that has racial overtones it is racist
to look at an asian-american white house
correspondent and say ask china this
isn't happening in a vacuum this is part
of a pattern of behavior from the
president that goes back many years so
he's he doesn't have the benefit of the
doubt that someone might have if for the
first time ever in their life they made
a comment like that to a reporter that
wasn't the first time in his life you
made that comment he talks about trying
to at every single press conference
didn't we have a controversy like a
month and a half ago where he kept
calling it the Chinese virus right have
we all hit our heads and experienced
short-term memory loss I understand that
we now live in in the in the world of
interstellar we're on like the water
planet and every minute is seven years
long and all of this but it was like
four weeks ago when we had an entire
national controversy over Trump saying
Chinese virus was he doing that for the
benefit of why sure Chang ridiculous
ridiculous he doesn't get the benefit of
the doubt and then you got Rachel Maddow
something is wrong with from something's
wrong with clearly something is broken
in Trump or maybe you always thought
something was broken and now you have
your confirmation bias Rachel Maddow
ridiculous ridiculous what what what
great
what great journalism in our media does
first they tell us that we can't leave
our houses without a vaccine then they
refused to give us statistics on the
zero prevalence test so we know what the
actual risk factors are by population
then
they suggest that everybody who's a
Republican governor is bad even if
Democratic governors are doing the exact
same thing and then they suggest that a
president Trump tells the reporter to
ask China about deaths abroad but that's
because the reporter is Chinese that
hell is wrong with these people
and then you wonder why American trust
in the media's at an all-time low I
wonder I cannot imagine why Rachel
Maddow the president right now in the
midst of this crisis is visibly
struggling there is something wrong or
he's just not doing okay I don't know
but the president apparently just is not
able to keep it together right now in
his public appearances what is wrong
with the president today we don't know I
mean something's wrong I mean whether or
not you you know like the president or
not whether you enjoy his public effect
or not on the on a regular basis it's
clear that there's something wrong oh is
that clear is that clear or is it
there's something wrong with the media
Trump has been Trump this whole time I'm
old enough to remember when the media
used to ask questions that we're not
entirely geared toward mr. Trump you're
very bad orange and large why why are
your hands so tiny mr. president are you
just angry because I'm Chinese mr.
president our genius me how dare how
dare Trump how dare he how dare he it's
just absurd him meanwhile these same
media who are asking serious questions
of Trump like why are you so mean bad in
Orange refuse to ask any serious
questions of anyone inside the Obama
team about what they are now calling
Obama gate so President Trump yesterday
was asked about what Obama did cuz he
used the term Obama gained on Twitter
and he says listen everybody knows what
Obama did right now here's the thing
everybody know what Obama did anyway
here's President Trump yesterday talking
about how everybody knows I'm going to
explain what Obama did momentarily and
it ain't great I'll explain in just one
second but here is a president Trump
yesterday Obama gained it's been going
on for a long time it's been going on
from before I even get elected and it's
a disgrace that it happened and if you
look at what's gone on and if you look
at now all of this information that's
being released and from what I
understand that's only the beginning
what if the crime exactly then you think
you know what the crime is the crime is
very obvious to everybody what you have
to do is read the newspapers except
yours okay so the crime is not obvious
to everybody and it's not obvious
exactly that Obama committed a crime
here is what did happen with the Mike
Flynn stuff and the fact that the media
have generally been unwilling to cover
it is pretty astonishing actually there
I'm gonna give credit where credit is
due one person who actually asked the
right question today was George
Stephanopoulos I know shocks me to
George Stephanopoulos over at ABC News
he had Joe Biden on his program do we
have this clip and Joe Biden was
specifically asked about whether he was
about whether he was in the loop on all
the Mike Flynn stuff and he says no I
never knew about any of the Mike Flynn
stuff we know he was in an oval office
meeting where Barack Obama specifically
asked Sally Yates to her surprise about
how things were going well thought with
all the Michael Flynn stuff so Biden was
in fact in the loop here he was
basically pretending he was not in the
loop this is this is an untrue statement
from Joe Biden and good for
Stephanopoulos for asking it I know
nothing about those moves to investigate
Michael Flynn number one number two this
is all about diversion yet you say you
didn't know anything about it but you
were reported to be in a January 5th
2017 meeting where you and the president
were briefed on the FBI's planned a
question a Michael Michael Flynn over
those conversations he had with the
Russian ambassador kiss lyac
now I thought you asked me whether or
not I had anything to do with him being
prosecuted okay I'm sorry I was aware
that there was that there they asked for
an investigation but that's all I know
about it and I don't think anything else
oh is that all
so you just misheard the question okay
well it seems like it's kind of asking
for an investigation when you know more
than the DOJ the head of the Acting
Director of the DOJ Sally gates and that
you bring it up in front of Sally gates
and James Comey
so here's the timeline here this is what
Trump is talking about and serious
questions should be asked here because
Barack Obama goes out he says things
like the Trump administration is
undermining the rule of law and then you
get this posturing letter from 2000 DOJ
officials what we call low-level DOJ
officials calling for Bill Bars
resignation here's exactly what happened
here's the timeline so Flynn first of
all Obama claimed that Flynn was charged
with perjury he was never charged with
perjury he was charged with lying to the
FBI in the course of an investigation
which is a separate and far lesser
offense particularly given the fact that
his alleged lie was immaterial to any
underlying crime which is something the
FBI basically acknowledges at this point
in fact as Americans have found
over the past couple of weeks Flynn
wasn't supposed to be the subject of any
investigation at all the FBI had decided
to close an investigation into Flynn
January 2017 it'd be January 4th 2017
even after these supposedly nefarious
calls between Flynn and the Russian
ambassador Sergei Kiss lyac in fact the
FBI had the transcripts of the calls
they knew that nothing inappropriate was
said on the calls
that's when disgraced former FBI agent
Peter struck that's the same guy who
pledged his lover Lisa Paige that there
would be an insurance policy against
Trump intervened and suggested that the
investigation be kept open the very next
day during an oval office meeting
President Obama himself asked the FBI
director James Comey
about the Flynn kiss Leone
communications and then Comey up the
ante he avoided following normal FBI
White House protocols in order to
interview Flynn his deputy Andrew McCabe
avoided informing Flynn of his rights
still the FBI agents who conducted the
interview said they didn't actually
think that Flynn was lying during the
interview as it turns out there were
notes between FBI officials at the time
asked him what's our goal truth
admission or to get him to lie so we can
prosecute him and get him fired Flynn
with later plead guilty to one count of
lying to the FBI at least in part
because the FBI was threatening his son
with prosecution in other words he took
the plea deal because you don't want a
son to go to jail this should be a
massive scandal and members the Obama
administration should be under the gun
for it because the reality is that they
perverted the rules of law in order to
confirm what they thought was happening
now best-case scenario here is that they
were convinced that there was something
nefarious going on inside the Trump
campaign and they were basically winking
and nodding at the Carter page FISA
warrant and at the attempt to bend the
rule of law regarding Michael Flynn the
more the more sinister idea is that they
really knew there was nothing there with
Trump and Russia but they were willing
to sort of create the impression that
there was by really exaggerating now I
always tend to attribute to stupidity
things rather than malice right if I'm
given the 20 malice and stupidity I
always go stupidity but at a certain
point these stupidity becomes malicious
once you're bending the rules in order
to confirm your priors about in evidence
less charge that the Trump campaign was
colluding with Russia and you're bending
the rules that does undermine faith in
law enforcement and the fact that that
the Democrats are suggesting the bill
bar is the problem here is truly an
astonishing astonishing development okay
time for some things that I hate
all right so let's talk about local
policy because it is truly insane what
local policy has ruts as I mentioned I
have two good friends who in the Pat in
the course the last 48 hours have been
the victims of crime in Los Angeles
nobody will be caught nobody will be
prosecuted the police basically told
them that you know we don't even have
Baylor anymore here so if we jail these
people they'll be out on the streets
within 24 hours how how much do
criminals know this here's how much
criminals know this the LA County
Sheriff released video yesterday of
inmates infecting themselves in jail
trying to infect themselves in jail with
kovin 19 so they could achieve release
they thought it would force their
release 21 ended up infected according
to the LA County Sheriff inmates at a
jail in kiste ik we're sharing a water
bottle then rubbing the same masks on
their faces to perfect purposely infect
themselves with Cova 19 because they
understand that the easy way out of jail
is to get kovat 19 and so they're
looking for release so they can go out
and be criminals again because of these
stupidity of the policy that suggests
well you know they're criminals so it
probably should just let them out of
here
just genius stuff from our local
government so here are the rules if you
go to the beach and you are six feet
away from somebody else but you're
wearing a mat but you're not wearing a
mask then presumably they will arrest
you or find you if you are in jail
because you committed some sort of
serious crime you just broke into
somebody's house then you will be
released even if you don't have kovin 19
because we can't have bail right now we
don't want more people in jail you
explain to me how a law-abiding citizen
doing something reasonable like being at
a beach ten feet away from somebody else
and not wearing a mask which is
perfectly reasonable how that is more of
a problem than actual criminals in Los
Angeles being criminals and then
basically being led off by the cops at
the behest of the political actors by
the way if you think the cops want to
let these criminals off you're dead
wrong the cops do not want to do any of
that it's just incredible it truly is
meanwhile good news the New York Times
is pushing some solutions for the for
America's cities okay they're saying we
got a problem with the cities because
obviously these places are overcrowded
they are hotbeds for infestations they
are the bedbug infestations for example
was a big issue in New York a couple of
years ago
there are bedbugs for they are they are
hotspots for infection and epidemics and
so there been a lot of expectations the
people are going to move out of big
cities now
which by the way it would be good for
the country it would be good for the
country if these cities would become a
little bit less centralized but New York
obviously the New York Times wants to
save New York their suggestion on how to
save New York it's truly incredible they
say the biggest problem is that in New
York there are some areas that are nice
in some areas that are not nice they say
this pandemic has prompted some affluent
Americans to wonder whether cities are
broken for them
it has suspended the terms of urban life
while accentuating the risks reviving a
hoary American tradition of regarding
cities with fear and loathing has
cesspools of disease an image that all
too easily aligns with prejudices about
poverty and race and crime so if you're
worried that New York has a lot of
disease it's because you're a racist now
it's not because the New York City
actually has tons of disease and is the
epicenter of this epidemic like
literally on planet Earth know that the
real problem here is that you're a
racist if you're worried about levels of
disease in New York and you're thinking
about moving out of town even New York's
Governor Andrew Cuomo has described New
York City's density as responsible for
its suffering that's not racism that's
the truth population density has a major
impact on epidemic spread obviously so
the New York Times has an idea they say
the problem is that the crisis has
prompted a flurry of fantasies about
abandoning cities altogether rooted in
the idea that we'd all be a little
better off at least a little further
apart social distancing is the salvation
of society this is dangerously misguided
our cities are broken because affluent
Americans have been segregating
themselves from the poor and our best
hope for building a fairer stronger
nation is to break down these barriers
so in other words because there are
places of differential spread in New
York City the best thing to do would be
hate to have a uniform spread inside New
York City and that way everybody feels
like they are in the same boat how that
solves an epidemic spread is beyond me
I'm not sure why that would actually
solve the problem but they say that the
big problem in New York is of course
that there is basically two facto the
de-facto
self segregation in New York City by
housing price that if you live on Fifth
Avenue that's not the same thing as
living in Crown Heights which obviously
is true what is their suggestion how do
they solve the problem of New York City
the problem of New York City is not
solved by for example ensuring that
every student has the ability to go to
at school the the best that the problem
of New York City is solved by forcing
the building of affordable housing in
the richest areas of the city which is a
genius idea that was tried in Detroit
and completely wrecked the city of
Detroit because everybody who had the
money then left because it turns out
that people
to actually want to live next to an
affordable housing area where perhaps
there are higher levels of crime or drug
use for example this is not to suggest
that all the poor people in New York
City are engaged in crime of drug use it
is to suggest that areas that have high
crime and high drug use also happen to
be very poverty-stricken and if you take
entire tenements and you move them from
one area into another area that will
increase the the life quality of people
who have moved from the poor area into
the richer area but it also means that
some of the people who are living in the
poor area of who work some of the
criminals right some of those criminals
will be moving along with you presumably
and it turns out that people don't
really want to do that or living in
those areas the reason they're living in
the higher income areas is because they
would like to live in the higher income
areas by the way also affordable housing
how he gonna incentivize that when when
New York City tried this with rent
control they basically destroyed the
capacity to build housing in New York
City according to the New York Times
America's cities are being profoundly
tested by a pandemic that has caused the
deaths of tens of thousands of people
and forced the suspension of urban life
even in cities so far spared the worst
of the health crisis the collapse of tax
revenue is forcing elected officials to
consider draconian cuts in public
service in such moments it is hard to
dream about what might be yet we can use
this crisis is basically the idea
inequality is an inescapable fact of
urban life but this crisis is a reminder
that segregation is an illusion the
haves depend on each other the rich need
labor the poor need capital and the city
needs both building more diverse
neighborhoods disconnecting public
institutions from private wealth will
ultimately enrich the lives of all
Americans good luck with this good luck
with this if you're worried about
Americans in New York City buying second
homes and leaving the city definitely we
should probably do is pick up a you
should probably put public housing to
rent like a an actual publicly built
housing you should probably put national
housing essentially you should put
tenements directly next to those Fifth
Avenue walk-ups that's that's probably
the best the rich people definitely
won't live leave they'll just stick
around and they'll continue to pay
exorbitant taxes in order to do so great
idea guys just wonderful wonderful idea
the New York Times never failing to
astonish okay time for a quick thing
that I like so I had the opportunity to
read a novel over the weekend this is a
novel about free birth of Israel
Israel it's it's about the the lead-up
to the declaration of the independence
of the State of Israel it takes place in
the period 1937 to 1939 and it's about
the Jewish settlers who are moving from
Europe into the Land of Israel about the
British Mandate that was very Pro Arab
and very anti-jewish it was about the
shutdown of immigration from Europe into
British Mandate Palestine at the behest
of Arab officials and I mean it is
pretty astonishing for folks who don't
know the history it is a it is a good
interesting history book that is pretty
well rounded thieves in the night by
Arthur Kessler worth the read Arthur
Kessler of course is more famous for his
great book darkness at noon about
communism but this is a very very
interesting book with a kind of
fascinating perspective on the
arab-israeli conflict go check it out
thieves in the night by Arthur Kessler
it's still available although it's not
really in print right now ok we'll be
back here a little bit later today with
two additional hours of contents
otherwise we will see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel I
douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by micro Romina hair and makeup is
by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo is blaming Europe for the corona
virus even as evidence mounts that China
knew about the virus covered it up
destroyed the world economy and killed
lots of people but American leftists
keep defending the Chinese Communist
Party because no less than their whole
political program rides on it then the
New York Times writer wants you to pay
for raising her own children a judge
issues a major ruling on transgenderism
before the case even begins and Slate
Magazine comes up with a new term for
monogamy all that and more check it out
on the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
you